[Music]
your last man alive
ain't gonna happen cena shuts the
chapter on this round in a sense trying
to tear away with a bit of a lead
and then one above it's going to be
seeking cena to shut it down 12 is on
the board ascend a one away
at that point i mean if you're a
gambling man you gotta say it's
tipped heavily in favor of us and
closing out the game there and then
z what can you find from this hiko
stand up don't stop
as soon as this is all the timing oh my
god there's no idea they have no idea
that's when a hundred thieves almost
knew they'd pulled it off when you break
a young team like that it's so difficult
to get your head back in the game
cnet's still alive okay nitro there it
is call on those years of experience
come on in now because don't want to
come back they've been it for years 12
12 we're going ot
before we get into the video i wanted to
remind you that every second counts is
brought to you by cisco powering the
future of esports
now when they formed hundred thieves
were considered one of the deadliest
rosters in valorant made up of a
superstar rookie and four veteran cs go
players they had enough experience on
the roster to be one of the best teams
in any valorant right out of the gate
gsm there's only two players left
there's a two versus four for tsm they
have to find a way out of this situation
but it's getting worse and worse and who
better than hiko to look to seal the
deal here in this grand finals as
cutlass tries he does all that he can
but it's simply not enough against a
hundred thieves a hundred thieves
they've done it they are your first
strike north america champions but after
missing vct masters reykjavik hundred
thieves had a lot to prove at their next
major tournament masters berlin at first
things looked good hundred thieves
topped their group in berlin and the
first two maps of their quarterfinal
series against ascend were pretty close
but map 3 breeze was a different story
entirely but he doesn't have much time
he has to make the move now and they are
just playing ring a rosie look at them
going around it he gets the fire one but
cena
claims the round for ascend i just got
called off
absolutely unaware of maybe starzo's
positioning but yeah oh
sealed he still looks for it finds nitro
huge impact for him luckily for him
starzo's bailed him out as well stars
are playing well from the site
tries to control these building threats
that were just kind of looming in the
background and steal your last man alive
ain't gonna happen cena shuts the
chapter on this round in a sense time to
tear away with a bit of a lead ascend
finish the first half up eight to four
just five rounds from victory and it was
thanks in part to an absolutely
spectacular performance from their
unstoppable jet player
cned
still showing presents but he knows this
could be a close coming in here and it's
from the back lines ethan denied keyless
beside him nitro's gone
this is the man we waited to see cned is
one of the greatest jet players in the
world and facing down 100 thieves in
berlin he showed off exactly why his
adaptiveness is very very like high at a
high level
he immediately sees a situation and
knows what to do instinctually it
doesn't you can already tell he's not
thinking about it he's just doing
players that are more like that and play
more off instinct than off of
overthinking will almost always
be better players cned dropped a
combined 46 kills across the first two
maps and ended map two a map ascend lost
by the way with an insane
307 acs you think back to kind of like
the early days of especially eu when you
think back to mix well on the jet and it
was it wasn't kind of this hyper aggro
play style and i think cned was probably
the only reasonable you know example of
of
somebody we saw do something that you
know wardell and tens were doing in the
early days of of north america but i
think he did it better ultimately teams
were trying to hard counter any team
with a strong operator player he was
almost single-handedly ripping hundred
thieves in half round after round they
simply didn't have an answer for the
turkish terror and his team was loving
it
the first half where every every single
kill people you know ascendant was
screaming they were like on their feet
like throughout the game and stuff
remember there was a lot on the line for
100 thieves after missing the previous
masters event in reykjavik this was the
big chance for this team of veterans to
finally prove themselves on the
international stage
again with multiple old-school cs go
players on their roster hundred thieves
had a ton of experience on paper they
were a team built to handle this kind of
pressure and yet when round 20 began
with ascend on match point things
spiraled out of control immediately the
important thing is ascend still have a
second player committed behind his viper
spin now that could potentially catch up
with the knees off guard just like cena
will find steel inside shop still now
just has to sit back and watch now it
might not look like it but this was the
moment the greatest comeback in valorant
history began you see before the round
even started steel placed viper's toxic
screen across a site yeah so the main
purpose of the the default wall i guess
on on a site on breeze uh for the
attackers is to deny a lot of those kind
of
long and and kind of deep angles for the
defenders particularly where you know
operators can flourish and whatnot and
force them to kind of take an
advantageous peak if the defenders want
to swing through that then
ultimately the attackers have the
advantage right um and also it gives a
lot of opportunity for um in terms of
the space it covers you know recon bolts
to be sent behind it lots of angles to
be opened up by the attackers if they
didn't want to push up behind him but
over the course of the first 19 rounds
hundred thieves didn't really find any
success attacking this site every single
time they tried one thing got in the way
well one player
seen it has to respect it has to go
through the wall as well goodbye one
gets away it's now on steel here
time is on scene inside this time but
still kept going he kept looking for
that fight and cena down to 35 hp still
a little better off here gonna try and
deny some angles from him steele could
do with this one he doesn't expect the
peak again it's still a miss but that
one isn't cnn's got it three for him
c ned constantly held aggressive angles
and picked off members of the north
american team so quickly he basically
ended rounds before they really began
but this time was different hundred
thieves had no intention of actually
hitting a site they just wanted to check
the site for info hoping that they might
find cned now you might be wondering why
the hell would they be looking for cned
when he had been dominating them all
game
well the answer is simple they wanted to
avoid him so as the round got underway
hundred thieves made some noise towards
a site using a bit of utility to sell
the fake but they still weren't 100 sure
where cned was steele then lowered his
toxic screen for a brief moment while
nitro who was sitting back cave quickly
jump spotted the site and saw cned
immediately hundred thieves started
rotating to the other side of the map
but steel didn't leave right away he
stuck around hoping to get a pick when
someone rotated to the other site
unfortunately for steel cena killed him
as soon as he put his wall down and at
this point most people thought the game
was over
it's match point for ascend 4v5 in their
favor and cned has the op it's over it's
still freaking over man i'm so confused
i feel like we've solo pieces
a million times over even though he
failed to get a kill steel's role as the
sacrificial lamb actually set up an
unbelievable play from hundred thieves
they'll put it into like a phone call
and they know it now kilos now knows
what's coming his way he's going to put
up anything he can to try and make this
trickier so they close the gap asana
great breakthrough kill but good work
again [ __ ] is still doing it but
he's here he's finally arriving but he
gets sent backing nitro out of nowhere
and now zeke in the 1v2 is it now is it
the next or is it never
zeke what can you find from this heco
little one stand up pico don't stop
as soon as this is all the timing oh my
god there's no idea they have no idea he
goes walking towards ct now they know
and the position from hiko should be a
a gift it should be the golden position
to catch this cross
and zeke can only take steps the gun
barrel shows he knows it they live to
fight one more round this round began
the most incredible comeback in valorant
history let's break it down second by
second while steele died on a site
hundred thieves took up an advanced
position in b elbow bone cold put down a
viper's pit on b main but asana cleared
that spot moments before so hundred
thieves knew they could avoid walking
through the viper alt and all they
needed to worry about was getting an
entry kill through b tunnel now it's a
race to the site c ned rotated through
the defender's side spawn while hundred
thieves made their way through the
tunnel as they work their way up elbow
the swing it'll put it in towards the
likes of quiles they'll put it into like
some bone cold and they know it now
kyle's now knows what's coming his way
he's going to put up anything he can to
try and make this trickier so then close
the gap asana great breakthrough kill
but good work again aston who is still
doing but ceded he's here asana exploded
onto the site getting two entry frags
before he was traded out by cnet but
while osno was doing damage nitro used
up all of his knives except one and with
hiko holding for the mid push all the
pressure was on nitro to hit his next
shot but see that he's here he's finally
arriving he gets sent backing nitro out
of nowhere and now zeke in the 1v2 is it
now is it the next or is it never after
his incredible headshot on cned nitro
quickly grabbed the spike from tunnel
while heco used his drone to try and
locate the last remaining member of
ascend zeek things were going well but
to complete a comeback like this hundred
thieves needed all the stars to align
luckily just as heco was getting off his
drone he was blessed by the valor and
gods
zeke what can you find from this heco
little one stand up pico don't stop
as soon as this is all the timing oh my
god there's no idea they have no idea he
goes walking towards ct at the exact
moment that zeke decided to jump down
from nest hiko stood up for a split
second everybody watching on twitch
could see hiko's head but because of the
timing zeke had no idea where he was if
hiko stood up before zeke dropped down
from nest or if zeke just waited a
fraction of a second zeke would have had
a free kill on to hiko and ascend could
have clutched it out in the 1v1 but in
that second zeke made the choice to drop
down and he sealed his team's fate now
they know
and the position from hiko should be
a gift it should be the golden position
to catch this cross
and zeke can only take steps the gun
barrel shows he knows it they live to
fight one more round they continue in
this fashion there's always always this
talk of you know this person's so
experienced and yet that there i think
is one of the best examples you'd
probably get i mean how many heco
clutches do you see where it's like you
can appreciate the mechanical skill and
blow our blar and you know the power of
the the outplay and the brains and
whatnot but that that right there is
just such a tiny thing it's not
necessarily like a highlight or anything
but it's the small things that add up to
make a fantastic player and my reaction
was just i was mind blown i don't think
i actually vocalized it but i was mind
blown that he actually considered to
crouch that was the most shocking part
to me halfway through this round it
looked unwinnable but now hundred
thieves were poised to make a comeback
the next round was pretty
straightforward ascends economy was
trash and hundred these cleaned them up
then in round 22 despite a better buy
ascend still couldn't cobble together a
win
c ned tried his hardest but 100 thieves
overwhelmed him in a 4v1 entry onto the
site in 1v4 this would be double digits
for 100 thieves so desperately needed
he's trying to play something almost
ninja and it's not gonna happen he goes
got him we're a double digits boys this
it it's looking like ot hype
round 23 was another eco from ascend and
a flawless win for hundred thieves
round 24 was the final chance for ascend
to close it out before ot
but they were too tilted and hundred
thieves strategy was too strong hundred
thieves identified cened wasn't on a and
then went in before he could finish
rotating what wait hiko what just
happened it's okay it's okay or is it
cnet's still alive okay nitro there it
is call on those years of experience
call on it now because don't want to
come back they've been it for years 12
12 we're going ot and then the two
rounds of overtime were nice and easy
for 100 thieves as ascends mental was
absolutely shattered see ned zeke
killers there's the dig deep there's the
team you need to be seeing kills on the
swing gets caught by nitro cena and zeke
the last two alive and zeke has already
tagged low this needs to be some of that
cned work and it's not gonna happen
nitro has outdone him steals outdone him
a hundred thieves take the lead this
could be it a hundred thieves on the
verge of destroying ascend ripping the
lead away from them as zeke and c ned
need to rise above and they can't do it
nitro to close a flawless round to win
it on and again
against the round score against every
aspect of this game a hundred thieves
just rose to the occasion hundred
thieves came all the way back winning 14
to 12 in overtime but that would have
never been possible if it weren't for
that single pivotal round hundred
thieves found an innovative strategy
cened was dumpstering them so they
decided to avoid him instead of fighting
him head-on in terms of consistency and
in terms of you know single impact i
don't think anybody comes close to
seeing it on on ascent which is no shun
to them whatsoever seen as a fantastic
player but if you can find a player like
that and and simply eliminate him from
the game by not even entertaining him um
then it's massive i mean it's no secret
that cned is a huge win condition for
ascend a lot of people were hyped about
cnet how good is he how tough was it to
play against him i mean you could tell
we were just going away from him we're
like all right let's find cena and go
the other way
that's the straw steel dying looked like
a miss play but it kept cnet busy for
just long enough that hundred thieves
could take control of the site and
neutralize his influence on the round
how were they able to make this
split-second decision to enact this
innovative strategy it's simple
experience 100 piece is a team of
experience that that experience showed
through the comeback on breeze how in
the world did you guys pull that off
uh we take the game more seriously when
we are down and we stop trolling as much
so uh it's it's easier like if we went
in and you changed the scoreboard and
said like we were losing the game 4-8
when it was like 0-0
we'd be insane with 13-0 everyone most
of hundred theisa's roster are veterans
of the cs go scene and their ability to
play calm under pressure on the biggest
stages is what helped them buckle down
and make the comeback ascend on the
other hand well
they struggled i cannot believe it
a hundred
pull
thieves
from the depths
of all these years of experience
and ascend now gotta be feeling the heat
i could tell you right now it's almost
silent out there and it has been
for five rounds now
ascend was an extremely inexperienced
roster this was all of the players first
ever major land and despite their
arrogance when they were in the lead
they couldn't handle the pressure when
the game started slipping away from them
when you break a young team like that
it's it's so difficult to get your head
back in the game whereas with 100 i mean
you could there must be like 35 plus
years combined of like you know veteran
land experience there um on that roster
which is it's worth its weight in gold
in in that scenario alone meanwhile most
of hundred thieves players have been on
both sides of this situation before
they've made comebacks and they've
crumbled in the face of unbelievable
resilience that incredible round and the
rounds that followed are proof that
experience changes everything at a high
level unfortunately for hundred thieves
their run ended in the semi-finals with
a 2-0 loss to envy but they proved that
when the pressure is on they can still
clutch it out and while ascend were
knocked out of the tournament by hundred
thieves incredible comeback their future
is still bright cened the star player
that hundred thieves literally spent the
map running away from is only 19 years
old and now he's gained some of the
experience that hundred thieves have
he's seen it happen
to him and that knowledge only makes a
player stronger 100 thieves had that
knowledge in berlin and their comeback
is proof that experience is key when
every second counts
in the next episode of every second
counts presented by cisco we're going to
break down one of the most iconic plays
in dota history but they're fully low
ogd that's sort of never two minutes
they get thompson thompson never do but
it's only hannah anna can you do it here
he's at our
he belt the goal
of his lifetime
it's sabs axe call from ti8 check it out
on december 22nd
[Music]
you